what's up guys i'm josh from the free
pilot training channel
and on today's episode i'm going to be
explaining zulu time
pilots have to know how to use this
because there'll be times when you take
off in one time zone
and land in another so you could see how
pilots atc
and other agencies could start getting
confused when we start talking about
times
to keep this from happening we use
something called coordinated universal
time or utc
now your guess is as good as mine why
they abbreviated this utc
instead of c-u-t i bet you as a couple
british guys who came up with that
i mean they do drive on the wrong side
of the road over there
now to really confuse you a lot of
people use the slang term
zulu when they're talking about
coordinated universal time
today zulu and utc mean the same thing
so to make things easy i'll use the term
zulu for the rest of the video
when we talk about zulu time this is a
current local time in greenwich england
people who aren't pilots call this
greenwich meantime
you might as well just forget this right
now now before i move on
something important to keep in mind is
that zulu time is not affected by
daylight savings time
but most of the states here in the u.s
are and that can make the conversion
kind of tricky but before i show you how
to do that i want to mention that zulu
time
uses 24-hour time instead of the
traditional 12-hour time
that you and i are used to the 24-hour
clock starts at the stroke of midnight
with a time of 000 hours
from there it progresses to 0 100 0 200
0 300 and so on similar to the 12 hour
clock all the way up to 1200
or noon beginning at 1200 it's no longer
the same
it progresses to 1300 1400 1500 and
continues around the clock
all the way up until 2359 where we start
the new day
at 000 hours the time 2400
does not exist don't be that guy that
says that on the radio
the nice thing now is that am and pm
don't exist
if i say 0 800 that means 8 o'clock in
the morning
then if i say 1500 that means 3 p.m
okay enough of that let's get back to
talking about converting to zulu time
because you're probably going to see a
test question on this now for the tests
they're going to give you a chart so you
don't actually have to memorize anything
okay so first let's talk about
converting when we're using standard
time
this is the time of year when we're not
using daylight savings time
this happens from early november to
mid-march
now in arizona and hawaii they're always
on standard time because they don't use
daylight savings time
okay so when we're in the eastern
standard time zone we'll add five
hours to get our zulu time then each
time zone after that we'll add an
additional
hour let's say for example we're in the
mountain standard time zone and it's 11
a.m the first thing we need to do to get
our zulu time is to convert to 24 hour
time
in this case it's pretty easy because
it's before noon so 1100 hours is our 24
hour time
but if it's afternoon we'll have to add
12 to get our 24
hour time for example 1 pm plus 12
is 1300 hours now let's add our seven
hours because we're in the mountain
standard time zone
and that gives us 1800 zulu pretty
simple right
then the rest of the year we use
daylight savings time that means we
spring forward one hour
that also means that the east coast is
four hours
behind zulu time that means central is
five
mountain is six and pacific is seven
don't forget that the pesky state of
arizona
doesn't use daylight savings time so
they'll be seven hours behind zulu
all year round the way i remember this
is that the word zulu has four letters
so during daylight savings time and on
the east coast we add four hours to get
our zulu time
then one hour for each time zone after
that okay time for a pop quiz
let's say i take off from an airport in
georgia at 1 pm
local then i fly my piper cherokee
around for two hours
what time in zulu will i land let's
assume we are
in daylight savings time go ahead and
pause the video if you want to try to
calculate this by yourself
okay so we said we took off at 1 pm
local time the first thing we need to do
is convert this to 24 hour time
and that will be 1300 local then because
we're in the eastern time zone
and it's daylight savings time we'll add
four hours
this gives us a takeoff time of 1700
zulu
now we'll simply add two hours because
we have a two hour flight
and that gives us a land time of 1900
zulu
this question is really similar to
something you might see on the test
before i end this video today i want to
show you something really important
about
zulu time and the chart supplement if
you'll notice
most of the times in the chart
supplement are shown in zulu time
but look at this weird plus plus symbol
behind this tower's operating hours
the legend explains what this is but i
want you to see this firsthand
first of all this airfield does observe
daylight savings time
but in addition to that this symbol also
indicates that during periods of
daylight savings time
effective hours will be one hour earlier
than shown
so during daylight savings time this
tower operates from 1100
zulu to 0-200 zulu so that note along
with the fact that this airfield is in
the central time zone
tells me that this tower operates from
6am
to 9pm local time and that time doesn't
change the entire year
hey if you would be sure to hit that
like button for me before you watch
this video right here i promise you'll
thank yourself when you go to take that
written exam
and if you really want to gorge yourself
on study material check out this
playlist right here
see ya